[Music]
crazy stuff happened over the weekend
secret service involved in a sex scandal
you following this story
yeah 11 secret service agents are in
trouble for reportedly having sex with a
prostitute uh while on a trip to
colombia yeah in their defense the
secret service agents are saying it's
part of their oath to put themselves in
ho's way
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what i like well you're gonna
give him that
that's right 11 secret service agents
reportedly had sex with prostitutes
uh people got suspicious when they
noticed secret service agents wearing
nothing but their sunglasses and
earpieces
completely nude walking around
no people are wondering how the secret
service agents were discovered
in the first place yeah and apparently
one prostitute figured out they were
secret service when her client pulled
out a condom and yelled secure the
perimeter
mitt romney seems like he's what are you
looking at
i'm just thinking about how i'm going to
explain that to my kid because he
watches the show
there's your first mistake right there
my kids think i'm a realtor
never in a million years am i gonna tell
him what i really do
he's a realtor yeah uh
of course it seems official uh mitt
romney is the gop candidate that's uh
you know not official yet but it seems
official mitt romney has already begun
the process of choosing a running mate
did you know that
yeah romney wants someone with a
different ethnicity who appeals to women
so his first choice is president obama
today in my hometown of boston the 116th
boston marathon was won by a woman from
kenya and a man from kenya
now it was a very exciting race both
winners narrowly edged out someone from
kenya
[Music]
[Laughter]
people are criticizing mel gibson
because mel gibson's trying to make a
movie about the jewish hero of hanukkah
yeah
apparently people really have a problem
with gibson's title for the film the jew
who stole christmas
[Applause]
[Music]
gets on the sled
the little dog with the antlers a
british historical society declared that
britain's greatest foe of all time was
george washington
our george washington yeah uh coming in
second place was adolf hitler and uh
third place
third place went to madonna's accent
yeah i have a problem with that
this is good news
brad pitt and angelina jolie announced
that they're engaged
isn't that nice
apparently brad pitt got done on one
knee accidentally knelt on a kid
they're everywhere you see
over the weekend a 3-d hologram of the
late tupac shakur performed at coachella
with snoop dogg
crazy yeah
yeah snoop dogg praised the advanced
technology that made tupac appear by
saying
this is some crazy weed
speaking of weed and i don't get to say
that often on this show
you know what the hottest new trend in
california is right now the culinary
trend
red wine laced with marijuana
yeah
yeah i don't
i don't have a joke for this i was just
asked to announce this by the california
board of
you've
tourism
[Applause]
[Music]